[Musique]
sur une île au large de l'Écosse,
quelque chose a été convoqué des profondeurs
de l'enfer,
quelque chose qui mettrait fin à l'humanité.
fils m'a fait une [ __ ] d'arme
où est mon [ __ ] d'acheteur là-bas
mr.  Mesdames et messieurs Loeb, il
y a une sorcière du cinquième siècle qui
a fait tomber le rideau sur Londres
et le monde.
fusionner d'accord
j'apprécierais une prophétie avec des
enjeux plus relatables ne devons-nous pas
sauver le monde ou quelque chose ouais d'
accord allons-y allons-y
ouais allons faisons ça
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
être  mon enfant nous allons ensemble ici à l'intérieur
nous le faisons mais ça ne marchera pas tu sais
parce que je suis un Capricorne et ta [ __ ] de
[Musique]
toi